let's jump to the first big story which
is not from timcast.com it's from the
daily mail
by administration says tsa will not
enforce masks on planes due to a court
ruling after sachi said i'm not a doctor
when asked why face coverings are still
recommended you know
i so this is this is it right now uh we
have a quote here i suppose today's
court decision means cdc public
transportation masking order is not in
effect at this time an admin official
said
i don't know i don't know what that
means if you're maybe an airport right
now and you're listening on your
headphones you're about to board your
plane and they're telling you you still
gotta wear your mask i honestly have no
idea maybe you can show them this and be
like i'm watching live right now they're
saying i don't gotta wear a mask well
that's what the tsa said but these
private airlines might still want to
enforce masks so we'll see
but i just think it's absolutely
hilarious that we're at this point now
where uh during the white house press
briefing jen sackey is like regardless
of the federal court ruling we're still
recommending masks and and then when
peter ducey says why
why are you recommending masks if we
don't have to wear masks here in the
white house and her answer was i'm not a
doctor are you a doctor and it's like is
it that's that's the go-to response from
now on right for anything you can also
read it like why are you saying i still
need to wear masks and she's like
because i'm not a doctor and i can so
yeah that's gross because i have no idea
what i'm talking about that's why yeah
it will be the go-to it will be the
go-to answer for everything every time
something happens in the economy i'm not
an economist i have no idea uh anytime
the jobs report unders and like enters
up you know lower than normal be like i
don't know i'm not a job recruiter i
have no idea why are gas prices so high
are you a petroleum engineer yeah i'm
not a petroleum engineer
okay
yeah i think it points to how they're
all technocrats at heart though you know
like that's like the whole thing is this
this this pivot to expertise is because
they want to control and manage
everything top down so they're like well
i'm not the person that can manage that
top down i'm just like a part of this
technocratic team and that's not like my
position or whatever but was there like
a memo that went out when katanji brown
jackson was asked to define woman and
she's like i'm not a biologist and then
all of a sudden some democrat strategist
went
that's it that's the tip and then he's
like he writes them up from now on this
is what we do
i am not insert specialty
but how do you guys feel about the masks
i mean what is this what does this mean
is this the end of tyranny or
is this like it's a step in the right
direction the united states isn't it's
not here because of of a fake trash
constitution or country or people we did
this for real to get to this place and
this is an example of the american law
working i think masks personally are
disgusting i don't know if that's what
you were asking about how i feel about
masks feeling the sweat and stick on my
face after five hours on a plane of
breathing talking about re-circulated
air yeah i just could never fathom i
really understand how that was should
have been better for me well ian came
upstairs and he was like masks no more
man i saw i was like dancing
like teachers letting you go home with
no homework or something yeah that's
what it felt like it really feels like
that and that's silly that's like
they're gaslighting us to feel like that
i think gaslight's the right word
because i shouldn't be celebrating back
to normalcy i should just be expecting
it and ready for it i mean ultimately
you gotta remember this is gonna be
enforced by a tsa employee and those
people are uh on average uh [ __ ] can
i use that word i don't know i think
they consider it a slur
the word itself is to mean slow yeah
yeah you can if you don't call people
names and stuff i meant to slur but but
it's really quick i think mentally
deficient is more offensive yeah yeah
yeah like it's because they're too dumb
to get it well no it's just like you're
assert like you're trying to make it
sound smarter or like there's something
wrong with them yeah i mean one time i
was flying uh back home from san jose i
was out of speaking gig and i have a
t-shirt on that had a grenade on it and
this dude tsa was like do you think you
should be wearing that to the airport
it's like excuse me
he said do you think that's appropriate
and i said do you think you should be
giving me fashion advice like aren't you
supposed to be like looking at my bag or
something
can't say bomb on an airplane tsa is
interesting i'm from the pre-911 era and
there was no tsa it was very felt very
authoritarian and weird when they
created that after 9 11. and then when
you find out there weren't weapons of
mass destruction in the middle east and
what the heck is this war on terror
really like why do we still have a tsa i
don't i don't think yeah they got
grandmas taking their belts off because
we decided you know invade uh iraq or
whatever the funniest thing about the
airport thing is i was flying a lot when
i came out here when i when i moved out
here for work was uh the most uh the
hilarious part was like when you look at
all the signs and say you have to wear
this you have to wear that they all had
like sponsored by purell uh sponsored it
was like it was like is that not the
most like corporatist thing you've ever
seen where it's like all your signs that
tell you you have to do this behave this
way at the airport none of it mentioning
covet
or anything like that uh at all i just
like to imagine that there's like
some you know
the the president of purell or whatever
companies he's like he's all his hair's
all disheveled and he's going through
the books and he's like he calls his
wife and goes honey we're not going to
have christmas dinner sales are just
really bad and then he looks at the tv
and it's like covered locked down he
goes oh
and then he and then he throws the
papers in there and he opens when he
goes get to work boys we're back in
business yeah now he's like super rich
and he's got the screech mcduck
that was one of the memes it says the
the creator or the owner of purell right
now and this guy's got like nine gold
chains on and and a bunch and a ring on
each finger it's like that's exactly
what it is then whoever invented the mat
whoever's like producing the masks china
china
wasn't uh that my pillow guy making
masks and they still hate him oh yeah
yeah that's right yeah he shifted
production to start making masks yeah
and they were like master bat now
we're not we can't support anything he's
doing that was that because i'm from
minnesota it was really funny like
people from minnesota just hated that
guy uh for no reason they have no idea
why they just they've just been told
that they have to hate him
we gotta pull up this tweet it's a great
tweet and you know let me just preface
this by saying
i don't i don't normally care to you
know mock people who are just not
relevant but this woman is apparently an
elected representative she is an elected
official this woman uh lindsay
sabadosa says today a federal judge
called it overreach for u.s health
officials to require masks on airplanes
and other public transmit transit and no
matter how you feel about masks you
should you should be really really
concerned that the courts are
effectively taking away power from the
federal government should we now
okay
okay hold on there a minute
it was a federal judge
who issued a ruling on a federal mandate
this is more of an uh i guess if you
think that the courts are taking apart
with the power from the federal
government
if if she's discussing some kind of like
oroboros
you know the snake eating it that's
eating itself
maybe
but i think she has no idea i think she
means taking power away from the
executive branch as it was intended and
that's what we have the separation of
powers for don't be charitable ian
that's my that's my job
like this is this is the thing that i
think we often do
is
joe biden will do something and we'll be
like well maybe he really meant this and
i don't know i i fully agree this is a
foolish and irrational treat tweet it
doesn't make any sense and she's all
sorts of names no no i don't have
anything but that's a that's a dumb
tweet that is wrong
the court's job is to
strip away power from the executive
branch if it goes too far for well it's
to interpret the law
uh progressive democrat and state
representative first hampshire district
i believe it's in massachusetts that's
correct and it's just
oh oh my stars and gardeners so i looked
her up and she's also before she's a
politician it says she's an activist and
i was like yeah that checks out well
look look i want to say
i mean no ill will towards this this
this woman she said nothing mean to me
um she just was
she just doesn't know what she's talking
about
and so the first thing i would like to
do is just say um hey you were wrong you
should you should fix that uh i don't i
don't want to rag on her for being you
know incorrect about this or not
understanding how the government works
but i'll i will i will say
while we try to be nice and respectful
because she has not you know maybe maybe
she's talked about me in the past i
don't know idea but if she's being if
she said nothing mean to me i want to be
mean to her i would just say i have
serious questions about her
her ability to work in government if she
doesn't understand what courts
federal courts are and what they do
that is a more professional critique
right yeah
trying to keep things respectful i guess
isn't the whole progressive claim that
they're for the people and power of the
people and all this and everything they
tweet or say or whatever is all about
power of the government no i gotta stop
you that i don't i think progressives
are are authoritarian and they've
they've i'm pretty sure they've always
been now i agree with that but i don't
think they claim to be for the people oh
i see yeah yeah
some of them may because it's probably
you know from authoritarian to
libertarian to a certain degree but
typically progressive
just refers to
you know
uh doing what you we think is right for
the sake of progress
so these are people who in the past were
eugenicists
i don't think the progressive movement
has ever been particularly
we want to protect all the people it's
more like how do we control the system
better yeah yeah and maybe i'm making a
mistake of using like aoc as the avatar
of progressivism because like with her
she's just always talking about the
people you know the people the people
the people but in you know in
practicality or you know in reality it's
always about more power consumption well
yeah like you know i mean tankies like
you know communists and stuff they're
saying we're going to help the people by
force right and that's that's like
that's you know kind of like aoc i'm
surprised people still defender it's
remarkable the there was that that guy
what's his name chris i think his name
is the union guy in new york who started
the he started a union at the amazon
factory they fired him and then uh he
started a union very successful tucker
carlson had him on and you know he's he
he's busted his ass to get this done to
push back against one of the most i
think amazon is evil
terrible company but we're all addicted
to it and uh aoc is nowhere to be found
and then
when he when he wins when when when the
warehouse votes to unionize
aoc's all tweeting like yeah we did it
and he's just like what where have you
been
chris smalls is his name yeah yeah yeah
good for him yeah
amazon russell brand just had a video
that came out yesterday about like
amazon has like an internal messaging
service in there and they're like
censoring words like you can't say
certain phrases like union or bathroom
break uh and it's just like is that not
the most authoritarian thing ever now
it's like they want to like reward you
by having likes like kind of like how
you have like likes on instagram and
stuff like that so it's like you don't
want to get a raise you want to get your
co-workers to give you likes on your
internal messaging service app for your
for your company that doesn't let you
talk about bathroom breaks and doesn't
allow you to uh to unionize because uh
what they say they spent 93 million
dollars on anti-union uh lobbyists or
something in the same year yeah i'm
looking at theverge.com some of the
words that amazon's banned with that app
master slave injustice ethics you can't
say the word
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
we'll see you all there